[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la comunidad
internacional mira con preocupación a
colombia país en el que en los últimos
días ha habido varias masacres que
recuerdan a los años más oscuros de la
guerra interna de ese país la lucha
contra los grupos ligados al
narcotráfico y también la lucha contra
el paramilitarismo demos un vistazo a
las cifras que hay hasta el momento en 8
meses que han transcurrido del año 2020
el observatorio del conflicto paz y
derechos humanos del instituto de
estudios para el desarrollo y la paz
indepaz ha registrado 45 masacres en las
que han fallecido 180 personas algunas
de ellas han sido líderes sociales
indígenas y también varios menores de
edad
para los organismos defensores de los
derechos humanos y la paz la situación
es sumamente preocupante en colombia y
también las cifras de 2020 son
alarmantes si las comparamos con las
cifras del año 2019 el año
inmediatamente anterior demos un vistazo
en el año 2019 hubo 36 masacres en las
que fallecieron 133 personas así lo
indicó el alto comisionado de naciones
unidas para los derechos humanos este
mismo organismo internacional indicó que
estas cifras del 2019 fueron las más
altas registradas en colombia desde el
2014 ya las del 2020 por supuesto
comenzarán a superar ese récord que
había registrado colombia en el 2019 que
dice el gobierno colombiano de esta
situación porque las cifras del gobierno
no coinciden con las cifras de varios
organismos nacionales e internacionales
porque el regreso de la espiral de
violencia en este país porque en la
falta de estado sigue siendo ese punto
crítico porque le da espacio a que hagan
presencia en las zonas rurales grupos
que están al margen de la ley porque el
gobierno insiste en llamar a estos
y asesinatos colectivos en vez de
masacres qué implicaciones tiene esto en
términos legales las masacres y el
recrudecimiento de la violencia en
colombia es el tema de debate hoy en
france 24 para analizar entonces este
tema hemos invitado a maría victoria
llorente ella es directora ejecutiva de
la fundación ideas para la paz esta
señora se encuentra en la ciudad de
bogotá la capital de colombia también
está con nosotros john marulanda
consultor internacional en seguridad y
defensa nos acompaña desde la ciudad de
medellín capital de antioquia segunda
ciudad de importancia económica en
colombia y más adelante se unirá a esta
conversación luis eduardo celis analista
de conflicto armado que también nos va a
acompañar desde la ciudad de bogotá la
capital de colombia su opinión es
sumamente importante para nosotros por
favor deje sus comentarios también sus
preguntas en france24 guión al piso s
sant y luego deje los comentarios con el
hashtag el debate efe 24 vamos a
comenzar entonces el debate y quiero
comenzar con jhon marulanda en la ciudad
de medellín
y en el nororiente noroccidente de
colombia un señor marulanda que es lo
que está pasando en colombia porque se
está recrudeciendo la violencia en este
país
santiago buenas noches y muchas gracias
por la invitación lo primero que salta a
la vista es la relación entre estos
desastrosos incidentes y la ubicación
geográfica de los mismos que es
precisamente en donde se da la mayor
extensión de cultivos distintos de coca
lo que lleva a que la mayoría de
analistas estén de acuerdo en que esta
serie de masacres están ligadas al
narcotráfico algunos analistas le dan
más peso a una cosa que a otra pero
ahora no hay un sentido general de que
el narcotráfico está jugando un papel en
este en estos incidentes los campesinos
los indígenas que viven precisamente en
esta región con la mayor cantidad de
cultivos están siendo víctimas de el
fenómeno del narcotráfico de la pelea
entre diferentes bandas que están
ligadas no solamente al cultivo sino al
procesamiento y a las rutas del
narcotráfico
y el 70 por ciento de la presión de
cocaína más o menos está saliendo por el
pacífico
y también se ve la presencia de miembros
desde hace rato miembros de diferentes
carteles mexicanos el de sinaloa y
jalisco nueva generación que han venido
abordando con mucho interés el manejo de
toda esta producción definitivamente
colombia es el primer productor mundial
de cocaína y eso pues por supuesto trae
consecuencias y una de esas
consecuencias es esta violencia que
parece estarse reciclando sería en la
cual participan activamente grupos
narcoterroristas de las farc y el área
victoria en la ciudad de bogotá le
pregunto qué es lo que está pasando
desde su perspectiva para que en
colombia se está recrudeciendo la
violencia ya jhon marulanda desde la
ciudad de medellín o se estaba dando su
punto de vista
sí bueno muchísimas gracias por
invitarme a support a su programa pero
yo creo que lo que nos está sucediendo
es una combinación de elementos
coyunturales con otros elementos que son
estructurales digamos en términos de los
coyunturales pues es evidentemente todo
lo que ha venido sucediendo en los
últimos años desde la desmovilización de
las farc a partir de la de la firma del
acuerdo de paz con las farc en donde lo
que ha venido sucediendo es una
fragmentación muy grande de una serie de
organizaciones que por distintos motivos
y distintas y con distintas lógicas muy
regionales y digamos ejercen este tipo
este tipo de violencia
que tiene que ver pues desde obviamente
la relación con las economías ilegales y
las rentas y el control sobre las rentas
ilegales pero también hay procesos que
tienen que ver con control con social
con ciclos de retaliación y otros que
francamente pues no sabemos
y esto se combina digamos con unas
circunstancias estructurales en donde
pues seguimos sin lograr cómo resolver
de fondo las fragilidades y la
ineficacia del estado para proteger y
para hacer cumplir los derechos
ciudadanos en esas zonas de la periferia
colombiana más afectadas por estas
economías
este panorama que usted y yo nos
describe para quienes hemos vivido de
cerca el conflicto colombiano es el
mismo escenario de hace varias décadas
atrás el gobierno colombiano y el estado
colombiano específicamente no porque no
solamente este gobierno sino que esta
problemática se ha visto a lo largo de
los diferentes gobiernos qué pasa con el
estado colombiano que no puede hacer
presencia en la totalidad del territorio
y le cede espacio a estos grupos
delincuenciales porque es la misma
discusión que se ha tenido en este país
a lo largo de los años
reclamo que se le hace el estado y no
cambia
a ver no yo yo quisiera hacer como una
aclaración primero es distinto digamos
estamos en un escenario distinto en
términos de que estamos en unos niveles
realmente muy diferentes a lo que
sucedía en el pasado a lo que sucedía en
los enfrentamientos entre grupos
paramilitares y grupos de guerrilla de
guerrilla digamos estamos en un
escenario mucho más fragmentado
y en unos niveles de violencia muy
distintos o sea no olvidemos que
nosotros llegamos a tener más o menos
según registra en memoria histórica
llegamos a tener un pico por ejemplo de
más de más de 1.400 víctimas de
de este tipo de masacres por allá a
principios del 2000 entonces yo creo que
estamos en un escenario lo primero que
hay que decir estamos en un escenario
muy distinto en donde nosotros ya hemos
tenido diversos procesos de
desmovilización de grupos tanto de
grupos paramilitares como de las farc
entonces este es un escenario distinto y
lo tenemos que entender así lo otro es
que si tal vez si la constante la
constante que tenemos es que seguimos
teniendo muchas dificultades para tener
un estado y construir un estado legítimo
y eficaz en la periferia colombiana
ahora esto es una situación que es cada
vez más focalizada que esa es otra
diferencia seguimos teniendo unas zonas
muy azotados por la violencia pero estas
son unas zonas mucho más focalizadas en
unos sitios del que no hemos logrado
terminar de pacificar en colombia sí
pero pues no estamos hablando como en
años en asia hace más de una década de
que más de la mitad
país tenía situaciones más de la mitad
de los municipios del país tenían alguna
situación de conflicto armado activo
pero en esencia sigue siendo falta de
presencia del estado en un menor
porcentaje de acuerdo a lo que usted
dice incorpora a esta conversación la
luis eduardo celis en la ciudad de
bogotá que nos va a dar su opinión sobre
su perspectiva de lo que está sucediendo
en colombia que está llevando al
reconocimiento de estos hechos de
violencia y si aquí el común denominador
y tal vez lo que es transversal es
precisamente lo que está discutiendo con
maria victòria la falta de la presencia
del estado
si ven un saludo a toda la teleaudiencia
de frank para esta oportunidad yo creo
que lo que está pasando en colombia es
que hay unas tareas históricas enormes
por hacer que están contempladas en el
acuerdo de paz firmado entre el
presidente santos y las farc
hace cuatro años y que desafortunada
frente este gobierno incumple esas
tareas tiene que ver con un desarrollo
rural en una buena parte del territorio
colombiano y con una política concertada
para la erradicación de cultivos
entonces en ambas cosas este gobierno
incumple o sea no cumple con el tema del
desarrollo rural no cumple con el
acuerdo de paz e incumple con una
política concertada en el tema de
narcóticos entonces todo eso hace que
este desorden territorial lleve a esta
criminalidad es el fracaso de un
gobierno que no tiene una política
adecuada para tratar por estudiantes
y yo en marulanda en la ciudad de
medellín ya la de la palabra media
victoria que quiere refutar algunos
puntos y para cerrar esta ronda adelante
john opinión yo estoy yo estoy de
acuerdo con la analista
primero de que si es tradicional la
ausencia de estado allí yo iría más allá
el estado y sí ha estado presente pero a
través de la fuerza a través de
militares y policías y no ha solventado
en realidad las condiciones básicas
mínimas que nos comunidad requieren por
un lado ahora yo personalmente no creo
que esto se ha focalizado y
regionalizado si usted mira en los
últimos incidentes y perturbaciones que
hubo en bogotá y de otras ciudades los
principales actores de estas
destituciones y vandalismo y demás según
su propia confesión estuvieron
financiados por las farc que está
operando en el putumayo está operando en
guaviare y demás que tiene grandes
cultivos de hoja de coca también en
donde el narcotráfico está presente
luego
que por el momento eso está en los dos
principales áreas de producción frontera
con ecuador y frontera con venezuela
pero es evidente para mí que esta
dinámica puede crecer y puede llegar
fácilmente al centro del país ahora sí
maria victoria en bogotá su opinión
no a ver yo yo quisiera pues por un lado
insistir en que si llevamos los datos
son muy claros y nosotros pues hemos
publicado distintos informes acabamos de
publicar un informe de hecho sobre sobre
dónde están focalizadas digamos la
confrontación armada y digamos la
geografía es muy clara y es muy es muy
focalizada que haya eventos pero no
desconozco un poco lo que lo que yo
estaba mencionando sobre cómo está como
estrategia de bogotá en fin quisiera
como escuchar un poco más sobre eso de
las farc en bogotá porque pues pues
probablemente puedan hacer actos
terroristas como ya distintas
organizaciones armadas lo han hecho en
colombia en grandes ciudades pero de ahí
hablar que están controlando y no sé 200
300 municipios como sucedía en el pasado
realmente
real
eso ese no es el caso estamos en otro en
otro escenario con unos niveles muy
distintos
yo quería simplemente hacer una
anotación respecto del tema de la
presencia del estado
y yo digo algo que coincido en el
sentido de que si digamos lo que
tendemos a hacer es entender como
presencia del estado sobre todo desde el
centro es mandar operaciones militares y
ante estas zonas donde están sucediendo
estos hechos son las zonas que están más
militarizadas en colombia desde hace
varios años con operaciones militares
permanentes lo que creo es que es un
tema de eficacia y fragilidad y
capacidades entonces es un tema digamos
de cómo se construyen esas capacidades
como se entiende desde el centro que hay
que construir estas capacidades con lo
que hay en el territorio en el
territorio hay algunas capacidades y hay
autoridades locales entonces yo creo que
hay que empezar a desterrar esta idea de
que es la falta de presencia del estado
la falta de eficacia del estado y la
eficacia se construye para la victoria
sigo con usted para revertir la ronda
y para cerrar este tema de la presencia
del estado entonces cómo revertir eso
que usted dice esa eficacia esa
capacidad de poder llegar haciendo uso
de las autoridades locales cómo revertir
eso porque tal parece entonces que eso
es lo que no ha falla lo que ha fallado
en este escenario para garantizar la
seguridad de estas poblaciones alejadas
algunas de ellas con unas vías de acceso
muy complicadas están muy apartadas de
de centros urbanos y es muy difícil
hacer presencia allí
bueno yo yo yo lo que creo es que
realmente siempre hemos pensado como en
esta idea de que vamos a llevar el
estado allá cuando en realidad de lo que
se trata y yo creo que en eso el acuerdo
de paz era era bastante claro de lo que
se trata es construir estado con con el
territorio incluyendo digamos porque en
muchos de estos territorios tenemos
incluso autoridades étnicas entonces
entonces es no desconocer eso que hay en
el territorio y enfocarse en qué es lo
que hay que fortalecer es que lo que
pasa es que aquí lo que hacemos en
colombia en general lo que ha sucedido
es que desde la nación se dictan unas
políticas se le asignan unas
responsabilidades a los territorios pero
sin recursos y sin capacidades humanas
entonces esa es la lógica que hay que
revertir eso es un proceso de largo
plazo por eso el acuerdo de paz
digamos planteaba un plazo de digamos de
cómo se iban a cerrar esas brechas con
estos territorios
de 12 15 años yo creo que ese es un
espacio es un período corto pensando
digamos que lo que tenemos es un
problema estructural de estado y que va
a requerir realmente un acuerdo nacional
sobre que tenemos que poner nuestras
recursos para poder cerrar los ciclos de
violencia en esas zonas sin poder
generar condiciones para economías
legales en esas zonas
luís eduardo su opinión sobre este tema
no yo creo que digámoslo estamos ante
una oportunidad perdida
coincido que el acuerdo firmado con
colapsar en el 2016 por el presidente
santos con un amplio respaldo ciudadano
es un acuerdo muy importante pero este
gobierno no tiene compromiso con ese
acuerdo este gobierno no tiene interés
en construir un orden de democracia en
los territorios y no está evidenciado en
su persistencia en política están
fracasadas o sea persistir en en las
políticas de persecución a los
campesinos que están ligados a los
cultivos de coca persistir en la
fumigación persistir la hd de fuerza
resistir en desconocer a la ciudadanía
para construir con ellos un orden de
democracia y creo que es un fracaso y
son las políticas de este gobierno yo
creo que todas está pero está el
criminalidad en los territorios obedece
al desarrollo unas políticas que son
fracasadas que no tienen ninguna
posibilidad del futuro de de salir de
ésta de esa dinámica de sangre entonces
estas masacres
a los líderes el recrudecimiento de la
conflictividad es una parte del país o
es que hay un gobierno que no está
interesado realmente en una política
diferente o sea es una es persistir en
un fracaso y este gobierno está empeñado
en eso en tu yo creo que no vamos a ver
cambios importantes en estos dos años
porque este gobierno se incumple
digámoslo en un fracaso y está
comprobado jhon marulanda en medellín
para cerrar esta ronda varios puntos han
dejado a nuestros invitados la capacidad
del gobierno en la eficacia una
oportunidad perdida dice luis eduardo
sobre este tema también la falta de
interés en poner en marcha el acuerdo
alcanzado con las farc
yo diría que
no solamente la ineficiencia o
ineficacia de las medidas del estado
para tratar de rescatar estas regiones
utilizando como dice el analista los
recursos que hay allá para construir
sociedad para construir el gobierno el
problema va más allá el problema es que
cada vez que el gobierno está empleando
solamente el recurso de fuerza está
deslegitimando a esa fuerza legal y
legítima del estado y las leyes
legitimando empezando por las mismas
comunidades que no aceptan la autoridad
que el estado les quiere poner ya hemos
visto el caso del donde secuestran en
donde aporrean a los soldados y los
policías en donde en cumplimiento de
órdenes judiciales la misma comunidad le
impide que los señores que son pedidos
por un juez puedan ser capturados y esto
es sumamente grave ahora las opciones
que hay para construir su salida ya
dándoles a ellos en sus manos pues las
tienen y no las podrían construir
tampoco ellos tienen su propia justicia
su propio territorio tienen su propia
seguridad con las guardias indígenas y
demás y eso
tampoco ha funcionado luego es muy
simple decir que esto se debe al acuerdo
de la habana yo más bien creo como dice
el analista que hay que buscar un
acuerdo nacional más allá del acuerdo de
la habana que yo traspasado rechazado
por la mayoría de colombianos pero
dejando eso de un lado si es necesario
construir un acuerdo nacional para que
estos focos que dice el analista están
allá muy centralizados en estas regiones
no vayan a generar un ciclo de violencia
generalizado yo sigo con usted y quiero
hablarles sobre esta polémica que ha
suscitado en los medios de comunicación
colombianos también en la sociedad
colombiana y ha llamado muchísimo la
atención de los medios internacionales y
de los organismos internacionales y es
esta discrepancia en torno al término
usado para calificar estos hechos de
violencia los medios y los organismos lo
califican como una masacre el gobierno
ha optado por llamar los asesinatos
colectivos porque esta diferencia que
quiere hacer el gobierno
cambiándole es simplemente esta
terminología quiere tal vez bajar un
poco las aguas de la atención que se
está presentando en el país llamándolo
cuál es su opinión
el término masacre es un término
bastante crudo que llama mucho la
atención y desanima en el código penal
es también la masacre no existe como el
término atraco no existe ya que se
utiliza más atraco que asalto armado por
lo que sea entonces es un manejo
político que se le quiere dar a una
realidad
y homicidios múltiples y simultáneos eso
es cómo se entiende por ejemplo en el
campo de seguridad más de dos muertos en
un solo incidente se considera una masa
que tiene un índice calificador de
riesgo de modo que el gobierno está
tratando de manejar políticamente como
usted lo dice calmar un poco las armas
pero si somos reales la situación no es
tan fácil de calmar y está a la vista de
todo el mundo lo que está sucediendo en
estas regiones porque el tema está
polémica luís eduardo también se une el
concepto que hay y al interior del
centro democrático el partido que está
en el gobierno en este momento en
colombia el uribismo ve esto esta
situación de violencia como una amenaza
terrorista no como un conflicto interno
como muchos organismos y otros sectores
políticos lo quieren hacer ver y también
pues eso genera discrepancias en esos
términos legales que también sirven para
que el estado simplemente quede un poco
afuera al margen de la situación
yo creo que es evidente que estamos en
medio de una confrontación política yo
creo que fue dicho y es que el centro
democrático porque es el partido de
gobierno no quiere construir este
acuerdo de paz no quiere digámoslo
cerrar esas guerras fracasadas como la
guerra contra el narcotráfico persistir
en las políticas es una es una
equivocación y no sino si nos tiene
donde estamos si es en una frustración
ante un acuerdo muy importante que tiene
que ver con elementos centrales o sea
hacia el que no hay una política de
desarrollo rural y se quiere hay una
política de concertación con las
comunidades y una protección a las
comunidades que quieren avanzar en la
legalidad esto va a ser muy muy muy muy
difícil o sea aquí hay un plan de
sustitución de cultivos que se echó para
atrás que era un plan concertado con las
comunidades entonces si no se protege
las comunidades que están en la
erradicación voluntaria como como ha
pasado muchos de esos líderes han sido
asesinados por mafias por bandas por por
delincuentes en el territorio pero
también ante la incapaz
estado de protegerlos entonces estamos
ante un gobierno que tiene unas
políticas que son fracasadas y no hay
que pedirle a unas políticas fracasadas
12 positivos porque ya colombia llega en
estos en el summa de 30 años 35 años y
está demostrado que la erradicación
forzada se no lleva a ningún lado
entonces estamos ante una ante un
escenario de un gobierno que persiste en
no cumplir con un acuerdo de paz que
simula el cumplimiento del acuerdo de
paz pero que realmente no hay un
compromiso serio y yo creo que estamos
ante una oportunidad que hemos perdido
quizás cuatro años maria victòria su
opinión sobre esta discrepancia en torno
a la terminología usada por el gobierno
por los organismos internacionales por
la comunidad por los medios colombianos
y también algunos medios internacionales
bueno yo digamos que yo creo que las
motivaciones del gobierno es mejor
preguntarse las al gobierno
yo no no yo me eso yo me supongo que es
digamos en el imaginario colombiano las
masacres hacen alusión a un período
realmente muy doloroso del país donde
hubo digamos masacres
diariamente varias masacres digamos
dónde habían tomas de pueblos y ahí
cometían toda clase de desmanes contra
hombres contra mujeres contra niños
niñas realmente pues digamos esa ese es
una marca muy dolorosa para colombia y
quizás el gobierno quiere como marcar la
diferencia con ese con ese momento si de
eso se trata
pues yo tendería a estar de acuerdo sin
embargo eso está al lado de el uso
digamos equivocado de las de las
estadísticas si en donde se presentaron
unas comparaciones que no había lugar
comparando ocho años del periodo santos
versos dos años del período que va a
este gobierno y en donde pues por
supuesto pues se mostraban unas cifras
inferiores pero cuando se hace bien el
análisis de los datos comparando
periodos que son comparables si se
observa un incremento importante durante
estos
años con respecto a un periodo
comparable anterior
si una cosita si me dejada si me dejáis
adelante una respuesta a mi querido
amigo luchó que los saludo que los
saludo aquí desde la distancia y no yo
yo quisiera hacer un comentario sobre el
tema porque ahí hay como yo aquí hay
unos problemas que son estructurales y
estos problemas estructurales no los
resuelve un gobierno hay que decir las
cosas como son la verdad es que este fue
un acuerdo de paz que se firmó y que
digamos se empezó a implementar sin una
estrategia de seguridad que lo
acompañará este acuerdo de paz no tuvo
estrategia de seguridad que
verdaderamente logrará asegurar
en las zonas de las cuales las farc iban
a salir y donde se sabía de antemano que
había otros actores que estaban misa
entonces aquí hay unos temas que son
estructurales y que deben ser atendidos
como tal y que requieren de un esfuerzo
nacional para para resolverse entonces
yo yo no estaría como tan de acuerdo de
echar como culpas de qué es este
gobierno o el anterior
yo creo que enfoquémonos en los asuntos
estructurales que debemos impulsar como
sociedad me quedan pocos minutos ya para
cerrar este debate quiero hacer las
conclusiones y no quiero cerrar esto sin
preguntarles si esto le pasará factura
al gobierno del presidente duque que ha
sido muy criticado a nivel internacional
por el manejo que le ha dado esta
situación por la presentación de estas
cifras
un poco inferiores las discrepancias con
los organismos internacionales y a punto
de terminar el confinamiento esperando
que llegue inversión de afuera colombia
para reactivar la economía esto afecta
le pasará factura del gobierno comienzo
entonces con jon en la ciudad de
medellín
pero le quedan dos años al presidente
para tratar de corregir lo que no se
haya hecho bien y marcar una diferencia
en lo que hace referencia a los aspectos
de seguridad lo que para mí es claro es
que las masacres o estos homicidios que
se están dando si van a pasar cuenta de
cobro ante la posible inversión que haya
para el país de hecho muchas de las
compañías multinacionales en las cuales
asesor ya están preguntando la
eventualidad de poder llegar al país con
esta violencia que se ha de renacer y si
eres una agrega usted los resultados de
esta pandemia que van a ser en términos
económicos y en términos sociales
dramáticos pues entiende usted una
situación bien difícil para que este
gobierno trate de marcar un rumbo y
decir que cumplió con la tarea que se le
encomendó lo que yo esperaría un poco
aunque como decimos en mi tierra en el
desayuno se sabe lo que va a ser el
almuerzo yo esperaría dos alientos más a
ver cómo se pone se filtra ahora tiene
dos años por delante luis eduardo celis
en bogotá su conclusión sobre este tema
que se viene para colombia para el
gobierno y esto le pasará factura al
presidente
bueno también aprovecho para saludar a
maría victoria y nos hemos podido ver en
los últimos meses yo creo que este
gobierno no tiene un interés en la paz
negociada o sea este gobierno
digamos lo es es consecuente con sus
intereses y en sus intereses está
mantener un orden
rural y excluyente y mantener un
ejercicio de la política autoritario y
ligado a las mafias digamos lo que son
los puntos que trataba el acuerdo de paz
de la habana firmado con las far en 2016
de superar pero yo coincido con que son
temas de país pero creo que este es un
gobierno que trabaja por sus intereses y
en sus intereses no está la ampliación
de la democracia sino la restricción de
la democracia entonces yo creo que
estamos ante un desafío histórico pero
también estamos ante un gobierno que no
trabaja por la democracia sino trabaja
por un orden autoritario
y para el cierre maria victòria a su
conclusión
no yo creo que sin duda esto va a marcar
al gobierno yo yo no veo mucha claridad
del gobierno sobre cómo enfrentar estas
situaciones en estos territorios si no
es con más de lo mismo entonces pues más
de lo mismo va a producir resultados
iguales
creo que la única posibilidad es que se
lograrán como tener algunas algunas
resultados en términos de justicia y de
esclarecimiento lo cual también veo
difícil porque la fiscalía no ha sido
digamos muy bien y muy eficaz en ese en
ese campo en colombia'
entonces yo yo realmente no lo veo como
una posibilidad de cambiar esta
situación ojalá el gobierno
logre al menos contenerla contenerla y
que no que no crezca de manera
desbordada y que logremos tener un
relevo político que nos permita
reconstruir un consenso nacional maria
victòria rápidamente cuando usted dice
resultados más de lo mismo estamos
hablando de tener que ver más masacres
no en términos en términos de no estaba
hablando de si puede ser que puede ser
que se siga utilizando esta práctica
terrible y tan dolorosa puede ser que
esto que esto sea ahora hay algo que hay
que tener en cuenta y es difícil cómo
proyectarse en realidad en realidad si
uno mira los datos de el incremento pues
de manera muy muy súbita si de estas de
este tipo de masacre se ha dado en los
últimos dos meses de manera digamos
vertical entonces habría que pensar
también y en eso no hemos reflexionado
mucho sobre cuáles son como esas
condiciones de estos dos de este momento
específico que hace que haya como esa es
agresiva tan tan abrupta en estos dos
últimos meses pues se llamaría victoria
llorente jhon marulanda ya luis eduardo
celis gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en france 24 haber expresado aquí
en este en esta mesa de debate sus
opiniones en torno a este tema las
conclusiones también los pueden sacar
ustedes en casa nuestros
muchas gracias por su sintonía siga con
la programación de france 24
[Música]